цей чоловік і жінка земляки обоє з
Луганська обої втратили усе що мали
через війну і тепер почали усе Спочатку
це поле готується під посів озимої
пшениці Тобто наш з вами хліб сили що
нового оржицьке Полтавщина на власних
полях Віктор поки лише вчиться обробляти
землю спеціальним трактором не так давно
він Ветеран родом з Луганщини заснував
агрогосподарство ми починали з трьох
гектарів зараз вже земельний банк
господарства налічує 70 гектарів почали
читати літературу відвідувати виставки
Ну і досвід в АТО також допомагає тобто
коли в АТО вводиш БТР або там водили БМП
практикувався Того так воно своє дає
тобто вже габарити чувствуєш все на любу
вантажівку питань немає ми можемо сісти
поїхати з тракторами Так є там свої
нюанси але все ж таки у те що службу в
ЗСУ обміняє на роботу і з тракторами та
землею каже Віктор колись би нізащо не
повірив до 2014 року він був професійним
прикордонником А у зоні АТО працював у
спецзагоні місто Щастя Луганська область
Станиця Луганська Кримське були
попасно
Лисичанськ золоте це починаючи від
розвідки місцевості і закінчують вже
пошуковими діями Тобто там де були місця
де ми виходили Тобто це територія
неконтролювалася не нами ні
збройними силами так званих формувань
ДНР ЛНР після травм від бойових дій та
психо психологічного виснаження чоловік
пішов зі служби Віктор ще не знав з чого
почати нове життя роботи для нього не
було у 2021 йому та побратимам держава
надала земельні ділянки як ветеранам
свої ідеї для бізнесу Віктор реалізувати
не встиг через початок повномасштабної
війни за станом здоров'я Віктор не зміг
піти воювати або ти йдеш воюєш або ти
допомагаєш Ми допомагаємо Тобто ми
забезпечуємо своїх побратимів це я
техніка це ремонт техніки запчастини
пальне все необхідне те що потрібно було
хлопцям ми намагалися забезпечити їхні
потреби виручку за той рік
приблизно 70% виручки ну це приблизно
пішло на допомогу хлопцям у планах
розширення господарства втім Віктор все
ще потребує знань у агросфері Він
вирішив піти навчатися за цим профілем в
університет а витрати йому покрила
держава на надавши спеціальний ваучер як
ветеранові подзвонила запропонувала
Пройти навчання тобто от за ваучером
Чому б ні людям приходиться вже
підлаштовуватися під ті
робочі місця і під ті професії які є в
регіоні Куди вони виїхали охочих змінити
фах як Віктор розповідають у державній
службі зайнятості під час війни офіційно
реєструють десятки тисяч 13 тисяч з них
вже отримали навчальні ваучери від
держави що покривають освітні послуги в
коледжі або університеті на суму понад
26 тисяч гривень отримати документ
можуть переселенці люди з інвалідністю
особи старше 45 років та соціально
вразливі групи населення 5 тисяч людей
вже точно закінчили навчання наприклад
люди які переїхали там з Донецька
Луганської області дуже багато людей
працювали на металургійних підприємствах
шахтах вони переїхали в області де
взагалі немає таких підприємств на
Західну Україну черкащину Вінницю і так
далі І звичайно їм треба змінювати
умовно кажучи роботу змінювати професію
дуже багато чоловіків знаходиться на
військовій службі тому жінкам Інколи
так вимога часу опанувати умовно кажучи
в лапках чоловічій професії
серед останніх прикладів дуже багато
жінок опановують роботу на невеличких
екскаваторах
машинних маніпуляторах перевозки
грузів для учасників програми є Понад
120 спеціальностей на вибір втім каже
директорка державної служби зайнятості
дуже популярними серед українців є
запити на опанування соціально
відповідальних професій на перше місце
До речі вийшло психологія у навчанню
раніше так не було тобто зараз лідери це
психологія соціальна робота
Я арт-коучка фасилітаторка тренерка з
професійної емоційного вигорання
допомагає людям долати наслідки стресу і
дбати про себе Дбаючи про інших так
віднедавна почала представлятися Олена
вона теж опановує нову для себе професію
психотерапевта Сьогодні вона як ментал
Коуч проводить заняття з переселенками
які торік втекли від війни на Луганщині
у Кременчук дії які допомагають нам
виходити з стану страху із тривожності
дії дуже корисні вже є наснага щось
робити і цікаво і цікавість у 2014-му
Олена була на місці цих жінок разом з
9-річною донькою вони застали війну у
рідному Луганську Боже бігти треба бігти
але прийняти рішення саме їхати це було
Коли всю ніч стріляли
летіли самольоти Сирена вила прямо під
домом про кар’єру тренерки з візажу яку
жінка старанно будувала у Луганську
довелося забути переїхавши до Кременчука
Олена Довго не могла знайти роботу Тож
вона долучилася до громадської
організації яка опікувалася
переселенцями і вирішила розвивати
місцеву громаду аж поки не почалося
повномасштабне вторгнення нібито я
зайшла на другий коло потому самому ж
маршруту але з скілами що я вже знаю як
їх використовувати Я знаю що буде Я знаю
який проміжок часу пройде і що я буду
проживати і це Той досвід який я можу
давати тим дівчатам які приїхали у
повномасштаб тобто я розумію ті етапи
які вони проживають я розумію цю втрату
ідентичності А хто я А що я а з чого я
буду починати нове життя і чи починати
мені його Да він мені відкладати свою
своє життя І чекати поки я кудись
поверну чи жити Зараз кілька разів на
тиждень оле влаштовує зустрічі з
переселенцями проводить групові та
індивідуальні тренінги також вона
займається терапією з військовими ЗСУ а
після цього бере до рук смартфон і сідає
за навчання завдяки ваучеру від держави
Олена здобуває академічну освіту за
спеціальністю психологія якщо Я копаю Я
маю копати глибоко тобто просто на
поверхні мені не досить тому я хочу
базову освіту це для мене підтвердження
того що я Професіонал Я на своєму місці
І якщо я маю ну таку академічну освіту
це підтвердження ну мого професіоналізму
саме для мене якщо в мене держава
підтримує такий спосіб Я маю не
прогавити цей шанс переселенці з якими
регулярно працює Олена зізнаються пошук
профільної роботи після евакуації з
рідного регіону у багатьох триває вже
понад рік і народом з попасної і досі
переживає ст РЕС від пережитого руйнівна
сила пішла повністю все
домівки будівлі все
поэтому багато людей з дітками які
виїжджали важно
прожить на что-то поэтому уже о карьере
сильно не думаешь есть какая-то работа
ты её делаешь ну В моих услугах не
нуждаются например поэтому нужно
переквалифицироваться чем-нибудь другим
пытаться заниматься у державній службі
зайнятості кажуть перелік кваліфікацій
для навчання за ваучерами постійно
оновлюється як і зростає попит на них
втім гарантії працевлаштування проєкт не
дає новоспечений аграрій Віктор що почав
нове життя після служби на фронті обіцяє
щойно його господарство набере обертів
готовий влаштувати до себе на роботу
інших ветеранів та переселенців А ми
такі люди
ми такі люди Ми шукаємо де краще
як краще де краще війна звісно
згуртувала деяких буде є дуже багато
ветеранів які повернуться до своєї праці
коли це все закінчиться будуть працювати
також в полях
головне це перемога